yes we'll have children after happened
with her I was wondering if there's any
way that there would molar dragons be
able to produce
well this depends on how you feel on
that crucial question of the sex of
dragons now threatens our are very
difficult to sex wrestle ever try to
roll them over a certain base there's
like the infamous mate stir or sub in
part who wrote a classic unnatural
history which is referred to in some of
the books put for the theory that
dragons like flame are beautiful and
change sexes in response to their
environment and the presence of other
dragons and things like that so you know
if that's true anything is possible but
if it's not truly important as wrong as
moral about scholars insist that it
would all depend on Danny's three Greg's
main works at them and
this is a question not to use all the
time sometimes I jot them down and stick
them in an idea foil I have more ideas
than a little right you know ideas are
regular easy which is something that on
writer doesn't sleep understand
sometimes you get approached at these
conventions well that's what science
fiction conventions but at book signings
we're meeting with people from the one
day in the world particularly crazy
crazy group and oh I've got a great idea
for a book well how do you like it yeah
you could write it up every Ray against
this and it's you know laughs it is
because ideas are easy the hard part is
the writing it up report so good idea to
get bad ideas you can I use to mean work
sometimes you combine a couple ideas
yeah
you never cease to have ideas some okay
a couple more questions there on the
aisle vector
was there any
Wow
I think somebody I think you know they I
imagine a characters very strongly in my
head but when you see somebody's amazing
actress bring alive if it's it's even
better than I imagined in my head we
have incredible costumes and set design
and all that stuff too but at the same
time what exists in my head in those
departments is phenomenal you know I
mean our crown room our further example
is in the paint Hall in Northern Ireland
this is the gigantic panic room you've
seen it numerous times in the show I've
been in on so location so it was
actually built from would be cold
your highness yeah we redecorated we
inherited their stuff and we ever in it
and it's a pretty cool looking origin
set pretty big before it television set
but in my head I'm seeing Westminster
Abbey it's pretty - compared to
Westminster Abbey or st. Paul's
Cathedral Ward versus all yours some of
the actual gigantic programs that
existed that castles and palaces
interest into history so it's hard to
talk my imagination or your imagination
s is one of the great things of books
and you know we can do great battles and
nothing like that but never as great as
what I can imagine my hate or what I put
down on paper one more question here and
then we'll wrap it up here yang Qi works
yes Father
yeah that being said what's your
favorite game play fever dream
I have a soft spot for me getting ready
to which was the one after my rock n
roll double but fewer name at least so
well together and almost destroyed my
career because it's all so badly I
couldn't stop my next book after it so
as much as I love it it's a work of art
every time I look at it oh god why did I
think this was a good idea it's a good
book they're both good books hopefully
they're very very different from each
other they're very very different from
nice and fire they're very different
from wild cards I like doing different
things